so listen um I've said it a million
times but I I love the show I'm really
happy to get to talk to you guys about
it uh congrats on a great first season
thank you so much
uh by the way I also enjoy the Four
Seasons backdrop
s
he's been here before uh once once or
twice so listen you guys I and I think
fans were unified in one thing on this
series which is you guys were fantastic
together
um this is one thing I'm sure of and uh
can you sort of talk a little bit about
um finding that Bond did you was there
anything did you guys talk before you
arrived on set the first time or is this
just actors being really good at both
I mean you couldn't shut this up this is
the thing but the first time we met it
was it was coming out of a Sophia was
coming out of a left with called with
their thoughts
and uh we um and we just hit it off
straight away I think yeah and we had
loads of cups of teas and talked on the
balcony kind of casually chatted about
our relationship together
um and and studies relationship but and
it kind of
we have time on our hands out in New
Zealand as well so we got to we really
got to build on that and
I think the key ingredient was that we
were just at ease with each other and
happy and you know naughty and all of
those kind of Secrets ingredients that
that form a good relationship I think
yeah I I second that and I think I think
um safety is a really big key word for
us as well like
um I feel like a wine makes me feel
really safe and I hope I do the same and
so the minute that you have that kind of
safety and Trust in a relationship off
screen what that means is when you get
onto a stage suddenly you are at
complete ease and freedom to take things
to distances that you may be you know
wary of if you didn't kind of have that
kind of tight tight-knit safe feeling so
I think we just felt like we were on the
same page
yeah and we pushed each other we
challenged each other we discuss things
we have little we succeeded and we
failed together yeah we did we kind of
went through it all and did we have some
challenge in times absolutely and came
out way strong we've got to know each
other more from them
um and looked after each other and
looked after the characters and and I
think saw their journey in the same
light which was um which was really
helpful but we had a lot of fun we're
quite quite silly because uh we just had
a really really we had a good time yeah
and one of the things about this series
is that you know you're part of an
ensemble cast so I'm curious what is it
like making a show where they might say
to you okay we need you Monday and
Tuesday and then you have two weeks off
oh I love it I think it's delightful I
think I have to say like it's kind of
Bittersweet in both Realms so it's kind
of nice to be able to dip in go out
because you can feel when you come back
there's this new kind of vivacious
excitement and what are we doing next
and we're all chomping at the bit to
restart however there is also something
in the consistency of keeping going like
um fairly recently we had like quite a
long stint of filming and um we were
kind of going at it for a for quite a
long time and that was really but I
think really helpful because you stay in
the zone you kind of like you don't have
to remind yourself wait can we pick up
where we left off where are we where
were our hearts where were our feelings
where were our even the voice down to
the voice and the accent was I pitching
her no I was like
um so um I think
um yeah there's kind of pros and cons on
on on both sides but I think yeah I feel
like now we're home it's nice to kind of
like get home and be home for a little
bit but I think when we were in New
Zealand we were like we just want to go
back we want to we want to we want to do
this yeah being in New Zealand for the
first season I think was a key
ingredient to us bonding yeah everyone
you know even though I may not see I'm
definitely not going to see every single
character in this shot dude it's got it
so but we were able to to bond
uh an ensemble uh a team a group of
actors a group of players
um if you like that that we that again
was safe we had each other's backs we've
met her every Sunday in Ben Walker's
house and you know we we just looked
after each other and became an ensemble
I certainly felt like I was I was in an
ensemble when I was out there and you
come back and you hear about their
various experiences on on set and stuff
and you're living it with each other
um which is kind of quite poetic in what
what our characters are going through in
Middle Earth as well I think so it's
quite it's quite nice very nice when you
got the roles or maybe even after you
got the roles how much did you feel an
obligation to like learn everything you
could learn about Lord of the Rings
knowing you're going to run into fans
that might ask questions and how much
are you sort of like I just know what I
know you know like I'm gonna get out of
the scripts well ultimately that's that
that's that gives you a sense of
ownership openings
um if you've got this is what I know
this is what I'm bringing you can go
down that route but it's hard to avoid
all these little
um bits that you can get from the text
and also what I think is is that
everybody interprets the text
differently as well okay there are some
given seconds and see that you have that
you can't avoid but there is there is
um there is room for interpretation in
talking to in talking as well and he
because he himself contradicts himself
in in some parts of the text as well so
there's no real answer to every question
but what's wonderful is that people have
a sense of ownership over it and claim
it for for themselves I think that's I
think I think that's great and as long
as you approach everything with an open
mind as much of an open mind as he had
when you read the text then then I think
you know you'll get more out of it okay
is there anything you want to add yeah I
think um my personal approach was
um
my personal approach in the beginning
was I know what I know at this point I
know what I know but that's my Approach
with every single
project that I've ever done in my entire
career that is my Approach at this
moment I know what I know
and so when I start to learn about
when I started to learn about who it was
I was playing what I was doing who have
I got next to me what are the
surroundings then suddenly I start to
control the level of kind of research
and the distances that I go and I kept
leaning back to Tolkien obviously
um Tolkien is all around us you know he
was all around us every minute of every
single day there isn't a Speck of dust
on the floor or a stitch in our costume
that didn't come from the infrastructure
or some kind of inspiration from
tolkien's appendices there is no doubt
in my mind about that because of the
strength of our crew and our creative
team and so you are immersed in research
wherever you came from that's what's so
lovely is there's such a vast cast of us
but all of us have come from different
backgrounds and different experiences
with Tolkien and and and all of the
stories and so it was this medley of
different ideas and different kind of
experiences all coming together and
saying right what have we got to bring
to the table some people had extensive
knowledge of the legendary and some
people had not much and but they had
extensive knowledge of creativity and
out of whole words off of pages and we
all kind of model together past crew
creative team production everybody and
um and made this thing happen but now
that everyone's seen the costumes how
much have you been put pitching them on
season two to be like just let me go to
Starbucks in this thing I know people
are going to enjoy it
yeah I'm
comfortable enough to be able to do that
but at the end of the day the actual end
of the actual working day you just want
to rip it all off and kind of just
breathe again you know it's it's um it's
quite
um it it's
it's an experience it's I've never
experienced it for on set this kind of
survival mode that you have to go to
it's definitely a new discipline that
I've had to pick up quick
um to be wearing the costume to be
wearing the the beard the wig there the
Prosthetics and uh and and trying to to
work with that but um
yeah I mean there's there's loads of
coffee on set so we don't need to go to
other coffee shops I think it was just
for me it's like on you know for example
Halloween you know being able to like
you know but I didn't think about the
fact that yeah it must be miserable
wearing that all day you know
the work what I'm saying is it's really
transformative I'll never forget that we
did a ton of movement which was really
helpful like kind of like movement um
out of the dwarfs move how do they greet
each other how do they bond how do they
walk how do they if they're frustrated
what does that how do they turn their
heads you know if they're to look at
something we wanted it to be beyond that
kind of human just to turn ahead like
what does that look like with everything
that they're carrying in terms of
that cried you know their inner carrying
and their outer carrying and and I think
um so I found I think the costume I
could speak for is both the man it
grounded us like the weight of that
costume is about as often as it gets
right you know you're gonna sit really
low you're gonna walk really tough and
every time you turn you do feel like
you're turning with a 10 ton weight
behind you and and so that was really
exciting because
it needed no more you were immediately
transformed but yes taking removing that
at the end of the day my goodness you
could like because you felt like you
were walking around yeah
I love the creatures of the Lord of the
Rings and I just want to know what was
your reaction when you saw on the script
and then a bell rug appears foreign
but yeah exciting it's it's one of those
again it's one it's one of those moments
where you go oh my life I'm in Lord of
the Rings
you know we
we live quite close to them so it's kind
of like another thing
I suppose of I was really excited for
the fans as well I have to say I Knew by
this point how excited they would be I I
am my brother's actually are huge fans
of huge huge brands that they've been
like my guardian angels on my shoulder
with so much and um I just knew when I
saw it I was like yes I'm hoping that
people are going to be really excited
about this this is um yeah this would be
a great thing
amazing amazing Die Hard fans so yeah
it's exciting and that note I gotta go
I'm just gonna say congrats on a great
season and I'm looking forward to season
two thank you so much thank you